Para muchos, Japón sigue siendo todo un misterio
- y no os pensáis que es solo porque Japón
sea el país donde pasear a los perros en
carricoches o ir a tomar café a lugares llenos
de gatos es algo normal. Para nada.
Haberse convertido en uno de los países más
ricos y más desarrollados del mundo y contar
con la esperanza media de vida más alta de
todo el planeta, en un territorio superpoblado
y con escasos recursos naturales, sigue siendo
algo que no deja de sorprendernos.
Pero... amigos, esperad un momento, porque
Japón no siempre fue la potencia económica
que conocemos hoy.
Todo lo contrario. Hasta mediados del siglo
XIX este país estaba bajo un sistema político
y económico que se parecía mucho a la Europa
de la Edad Media.
Por aquel entonces, Japón era un territorio
pobre, atrasado, cerrado al mundo y con una
sociedad fuertemente estratificada.
Ahora bien… La pregunta es, ¿Cómo se produjo
el gran cambio? ¿Cómo logró Japón pasar
de ser una pobre economía rural a convertirse
en toda una potencia industrial?
¿Fue todo producto de la influencia y la ayuda de los
Estados Unidos tras la Segunda Guerra Mundial?¿Fue,
acaso, el resultado, de un plan minuciosamente
diseñado por el gobierno?
Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, podemos
decir que en todo este proceso hubo dos grandes
etapas. La primera de la que hablaremos en
este vídeo, se inicia hace precisamente 150
años con la llamada Restauración Meiji [¿150
años? Sí estamos de aniversario]
La segunda etapa, de la que hablaremos en
un próximo vídeo [así que ya sabéis, no
olvides suscribiros al canal] tuvo su inició
al finalizar la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Pero dicho esto, arranquemos con esta historia.
Vamos allá.
(LA RESTAURACIÓN MEIJI)
Hace 150 años, la Restauración Meiji de
1868 terminó con el dominio que tenían los
Tokugawa, un clan que durante más de 250
años, desde 1603 prácticamente suplantaron
el poder del emperador y se convirtieron en
los grandes señores de Japón.
(Hablamos de un largo periodo durante el cual
Japón permaneció aislado de todo contacto
con el exterior, algo que al final terminó
provocando que mientras muchos países occidentales
se lanzaban a la industrialización, Japón
se quedara relegado con unas estructuras sociales,
políticas y económicas más parecidas a
la Edad Media que a los tiempos modernos.
Japón era una sociedad feudal, dominada por
señores de la guerra y que durante ni más
ni menos que 14 siglos se había comportado
como una especie de estado vasallo del Imperio
Chino.)
[Vamos, muy diferente al Japón que conocemos
hoy.]
Hablamos de un país que llegó a prohibir
el uso de sus puertos por parte de extranjeros
para evitar que su influencia terminará contaminando
la cultura y las tradiciones locales.
Claro que… eso también terminó con el
comercio y con cualquier posibilidad de que
sus rígidos estamentos políticos evolucionaran
al compás de los tiempos.
Esta fue la situación hasta que en 1853 una
moderna flota de los Estados Unidos llegó
a la bahía de Tokyo con una misión y un
mensaje: o las autoridades japonesas aceptaban
y permitían al comercio o se tendrían que
atener a las consecuencias.
(«Los barcos a vapor / rompen el descanso
de los halcones / del pacífico; / con sólo
cuatro barcos basta / para hacernos perder
el sueño en las noches» Poema japonés que
hace referencia a los barcos norteamericanos
que llegaron al país en 1853)
Evidentemente, ante una moderna flota de guerra,
tecnológicamente avanzada, poco podían hacer
las atrasadas instituciones japonesas. Así
que no les quedó más remedio que aceptar
y comenzar la apertura.
Ese fue el principio del fin del régimen
de los Tokugawa.
En pocos años, asqueados por la más que
palpable pérdida de soberanía, por la humillación
de sentirse un país pobre e incapaz y ante
la experiencia de haber conocido el ocaso
del imperio chino, los samurais [Unos samurais,
por cierto, mucho más modernos que los que
suelen salir en las películas] se hicieron
con el control y restablecieron el Japón
imperial.
Hablamos de la conocida como restauración
Meiji que, contra todo pronóstico, lanzó
al Japón a los brazos de un amplio programa
de reformas y cambio en prácticamente todos
los campos.
Al fin y al cabo, queridos amigos, ante la
enorme superioridad tecnológica, económica
y militar de las potencias occidentales, la
mejor forma de preservar la soberanía de
Japón no era otra que tomar nota e impulsar
el desarrollo del país.
Y ¿Sabéis que? Dicho y hecho.
En pocos años, a Japón no lo reconocerían
ni los propios japoneses.
Estos son los pasos que siguió un país para
dar el salto desde la edad feudal al mundo
moderno. Atentos.
(A nivel político se terminó con muchas
de las viejas instituciones y se introdujo
un poder judicial independiente, un poder
legislativo bicameral y un moderno sistema
de prefecturas para gobernar las diferentes
regiones del país.
Los viejos impuestos sobre la venta de arroz
fueron sustituidos por un impuesto a la tierra,
lo cual tuvo dos grandes ventajas:
Primero, facilitó el cálculo de los ingresos
que cada año obtenía el gobierno - al fin
y al cabo la cantidad de tierra no cambia
como si cambia cada año la producción de
arroz - lo que permitió, por ejemplo, diseñar,
financiar y construir muchas infraestructuras.
Y segundo, obligó a determinar con exactitud
la titularidad de la tierra, estableciendo
para ello un moderno sistema de derechos de
propiedad.)
Pero esto no fue todo.
Conscientes de lo importante que era el conocimiento
y las nuevas tecnologías, en 1872, apenas
4 años después de la resturación Meiji
se estableció un sistema de educación primaría
universal y unos pocos años se había creado
el Tokyo Institute of Technology y la Universidad
de Tokyo.
Y, por supuesto, además de todo lo que hemos
visto, se impulsó la apertura de Japón,
se atrajeron expertos y profesionales extranjeros,
para que transmitieran sus conocimientos,
y muchos estudiantes japoneses fueron becados
para estudiar tanto en Europa como en los
Estados Unidos.
El resultado de todo este proceso, amigos,
es que en tal solo 50 años Japón logró
realizar su propia revolución industrial.
Esto fue un tercio del tiempo que le costó
a Europa.
(De esta forma, durante las siguientes décadas,
el Japón continuó con su proceso de despegue
y cambió. Y fue también cuando empezó a
extender su influencia a países vecinos como
Corea, China, Rusia o Taiwan.
En 1902, además, firmó un acuerdo de amistad
con Gran Bretaña, acuerdo que no sólo impulsó
su industria si que cuando llegó la Primera
Guerra Mundial Japón pudo aprovecharse para
convertirse en un importante proveedor e impulsar
aún más su economía.
Durante estos años muchos emprendedores japoneses
se hicieron millonarios.)
[Ya sea por un motivo o por otro, al final
cuando los países impulsan el comercio, todas
las partes suelen obtener beneficios. Mr.
Donald Trump, tome nota.]
Pero amigos… así es como llegamos a 1926,
el año donde da comienzo la época más tenebrosa
del Japón. Atentos.
(LA ECONOMÍA DE GUERRA)
1926, el año el que el Emperador Hirohito
llegó al trono… donde por cierto permaneció
hasta 1989.
El caso es que a partir de ese preciso momento
en la década de los años 20, Japón comienza
a profundizar en su perfil más bélico.
En 1931, las tropas niponas ocuparon la provincia
china de Manchuria… donde no solo cometieron
una enorme cantidad de crímenes, sino que
también sería uno de los desencadenantes
de las tensas relaciones entre Japón y la
mayor parte de las potencias occidentales.
(Además, desde la llegada al poder de Hirohito,
el gobierno comenzó a impulsar la industria
de la guerra hasta tal punto que en 1931,
mientras las tropas invadían Manchuria, el
gobierno japonés autorizó e impulsó la
creación de Carteles entre las grandes compañías,
especialmente entre la industria pesada, es
decir aquella relacionada con el acero, la
construcción de barcos, maquinarias, camiones,
etcétera, etcétera.
De esta forma el gobierno instaba a las grandes
empresas a ponerse de acuerdo para hacer crecer
la producción lo más rápido posible al
tiempo que limitaban la entrada de nuevos
competidores.)
Y no solo eso, durante los siguientes años
el gobierno, además, inyectó mucho capital
hasta convertirse en copropietario de muchas
de estas compañías. Todo mientras el gasto
militar no paraba de crecer:
Por supuesto esta masiva intervención del
gobierno en la economía tuvo consecuencias:
las pequeñas empresas fueron arrasadas y
casi todas las industrias civiles fueron cerradas
mucho antes de los bombardeos de los Estados
Unidos durante la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Las consecuencias de esta economía de guerra
no solo fueron un gobierno más autoritario,
y una mayor influencia de los militares lo
que al final acabó desembocando en la guerra,
sino también el empobrecimiento general de
los japoneses.
Claro, había que producir material militar
no bienes que mejoraran la vida de las personas
en el día a día. [Más fusiles y menos máquinas
de coser. Menudo éxito,
al final todos mucho más pobres.]
Y es que, ¿sabéis qué? Esto no es nada
extraño. La historia nos enseña que las
políticas militaristas suelen hacer de oro
e impulsar el poder de una élite a cambio
de empobrecer a la mayoría.
El caso es que al final, como todos sabemos,
al terminar la Segunda Guerra Mundial, Japón
no solo era un país derrotado sino que la
economía japonesa estaba destrozada y los
japoneses habían retrocedido décadas en
lo que respecta a su nivel de vida.
Todo ello, por supuesto, además de la tragedia
de haber perdido más de 3 millones de vidas
durante el conflicto.
Ahora bien, puede que alguno de vosotros se
esté preguntando, pero... ¿Qué ocurrió
una vez terminada la guerra? ¿Cómo logró
Japón convertirse en pocos años en toda
una potencia?
Amigos, eso lo veremos en un próximos vídeo
aquí en VisualPolitik. De momento en este,
ya hemos visto cómo Japón dio el gran salto
y pasó de la Edad Media al mundo moderno.
Si te ha resultado interesante este vídeo
dale a like y no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik,
a VisualPolitik y también al canal de nuestros
amigos de Value School, que están preparando
muchas cosas interesantes. Si te gusta el
mundo de la inversión pasaré por allí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.